salut aujourd'hui je vous fais un
deuxième épisode sur le sens caché de
certains logos l'explication de petits
secrets de certaines marques
la dernière fois j'ai fait 10
aujourd'hui j'en ferai cette escapade
règle
[Musique]
pour le premier on va s'intéresser à
snapshot que vous connaissez très bien
on va pas se mentir moi j'ai découvert
la pluie un peu tardivement snapshot au
départ devait s'appeler peekaboo au peek
a boo c'est le nom du fantôme qu'il ya
sur le logo
sauf qu'ils ont bien un problème de
taille avec ça puisque peek a boo
c'était déjà un nom prix est déposée par
une société d'albums photos donc ils
n'ont pas pu l'utiliser professionnelle
à la dernière minute ils ont changé pour
ce match at qui est un mix entre
snapshot qu'un instantané et chat la
discussion c'est donc devenu snapshot
mais le fantôme le peek a boo est resté
sur le logo puisque derrière la notion
de fantômes se cache le côté des photos
qui disparaissent en numéro 2 on va
parler du logo d'apple oui vous me
l'avez beaucoup demandé dans les
commentaires il a été créé en 1975 par
ron wayne ti est un des cofondateurs
d'ailleurs dès le départ c'était une
pomme en fait la pomme faisait référence
à newton et à la gravité puisqu'il est
une légende urbaine qui raconte que
newton s'est pris une pomme sur la tête
quand il était assis sous un pommier que
c'est comme ça qu'il a pensé au système
de la gravité c'est en 1977 que steve
jobs fait changer la pompe pour qu'elle
soit croquer en arc en ciel et alors là
il ya des théories et plein d'hypothèses
sur pourquoi là pomme été croqué
pourquoi il ya un arc en ciel à
l'intérieur beaucoup pensent que c'est
une référence à alan turing alan turing
c'est un génie qui a décrypté le code
enigma des nazis durant la seconde
guerre mondiale mais qui était
homosexuel et à l'époque être homosexuel
lahoud éviter c'était complètement
illégal malgré son exploit il devait
aller en prison et pour échapper à la
prison il à croquer une pomme
empoisonnée plein de cyanure une sorte
de référence à blanche-neige ya une
deuxième théorique dit simplement la
pomme croquée c'est le symbole de la
connaissance là ce sera une référence
biblique à adam et eve impossible de
savoir ce qui est vrai ou ce qui est pas
vrai en tout cas officiellement ils ont
expliqué que la pomme croquée c'était
simplement pour pas qu'on confonde la
pomme avec une cerise et les couleurs de
la pomme n'avait aucune référence à
l'époque avec le ce qui deviendra plus
tard le drapeau gay et par extension et
gbt aujourd'hui mais simplement pour
mettre en avant le fait que c'était des
moniteurs de couleur en 3 je vous
parlais de quelques fact intéressant sur
think there were tilder alors tender
c'est un mot qu'on utilise pour toutes
les petites choses à combustion rapide
ce dont peut servir pour faire la lune
le feu par exemple donc une feuille de
papier du petit bois des allumettes des
journaux un allume feu ce genre de
choses tout ça ça fait partie d'une
famille qu'on pourrait appeler le teen
de verser du thunder s'est de l'aimf
donc l'application fait référence à ça
et c'est pour ça que vous avez une
flamme sur le i de tindall mais
forcément le tender ce quelque chose qui
s'enflamme très vite et qui est vite
réduit à l'état de cendres donc
l'application s'affiche clairement comme
quelque chose qui s'enflamment vite mais
qui durent pas forcément d'autant qu'on
est dans les marques américaines en cas
je vous parle de starbucks et thierry
mechler qui a créé le
en 1971 et qu'il ya aussi d'ailleurs
trouvé le monde la marque le nom de la
marque aux particules des fois il s'est
simplement inspiré d'une sirène
scandinave avec les cheveux bon pourquoi
pas c'était considéré comme une déesse
et là vous dites pourquoi une si réd 1
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce qu'il
voulait lier le café au côté séduction
et là vous voyez peut-être pas le
rapport entre la séduction et café mais
c'est quelque chose qui est utilisé
depuis tout le temps et encore
aujourd'hui c'est pas pour rien qu
encore à l'heure actuelle vous avez une
pub pour le café qui finit par waddell
en 1987 la marque est racheté par une
marque de café d'expresso italien avec
comme nouveau logo une tête de romain à
la place ensuite fusionner le vert du
logo avec la sirène mais il avait juste
un problème c'était problème de la
poitrine envoyer la poitrine de la
sirène donc ils ont remonté un petit peu
le logo et pour la petite histoire en
plus starbucks ça vient du nom d'un
officier qu'on trouve dans le roman de
moby dick
on arrive déjà au 5e qui me plaît
particulièrement c'est le logo de north
west airlines ce logo paraît très simple
ça semble rien et pendant est
extrêmement ingénieux parce que deux
dents en négatif on arrive à retrouver
le n et le w de nord ouest
maintenant que je vous le dis vous
devriez voir très clairement le n est le
wci on record de tout et là où c'est
très malin c'est que la petite flèche
qui est détaché ça peut nous faire
penser en fait simplement à une boussole
et si on regarde par rapport au cercle à
les placer ou bam au nord-ouest en
sixième on va parler d'un fast food
n'ont pas de mcdo pas de quick non plus
on va parler de kfc kfc a été créée en
1952 ça s'appelait le kentucky fried
chicken et en 1991
ils veulent quelque chose de plus
impactants dont qui prennent la première
lettre de chaque mois pour faire car
excès il ya une personne sur le logo
vous n'êtes pas forcément demander qui
sait c'est un colonel c'est surtout le
fondateur de la chaîne qui s'appelle
harland sanders et on va finir avec le
7e qui serait un petit peu plus long
parce que je vous en donnerai plusieurs
en vrai dans le viième ça fera des bonus
ce sont ces le goût un petit peu malin
et lisible dans tous les sens alors il
ya le logo de sun qui apparemment un
petit peu connue je sais pas si vous le
connaissiez à chaque fois qu'on tourne
dans 90 degrés on peut toujours lire sun
à chaque fois donc il est visible dans
tous les sens il ya le logo de hot shot
show mois chauds au chaud en fait c'est
d'une marque de lingerie et comme je
mets pas beaucoup de lingerie je connais
pas la prononciation de cette marque là
les filles vous pouvez nous dire en
phonétique dans les commentaires comment
ça se prononce
grâce aux y ait au h la manière dont ils
ont dessiné si on retourne le logo de
180 degrés on peut encore lire le nom
la marque est la dernière fois je vous
ai parlé du tgv mais il ya quelque chose
qui va remplacer le tgv qui s'appelle le
inouïe et encore une fois la sncf a fait
un logo qui se retendent parce que si on
retourne inouïe on lit je te le donne
emile louis le secret il est vraiment
dans le nom du train de la marque du
train dans in oui parce que il se lit en
six dimensions différentes
le haut de inwi le haut qui a omis du et
représente une bulle de confort en fait
c'est vraiment le message qu'ils veulent
mettre en avant dans notre train vous
êtes dans une bulle le oui de inouïe
c'est leur intention de répondre
positivement à quasiment toutes les
demandes
le new de inouïe c'est le message clair
que veut faire passer la sncf en ce
moment c'est à dire rapprocher les
équipes et les utilisateurs donc en
clair ça veut dire rapprochons-nous
hinault de inwi cellino de l'innovation
parce que clairement ses trains là ils
vont être connectés en wifi va y avoir
des applications ils veulent s'inscrire
dans le digital avec sa in de inwi ça
vous le savez in the year de danse est
un signe de modernité et enfin la
globalité inouïe c'est la promesse
qu'ils essaient de nous faire dans le
message marketing de dire le service va
être inuit je sais pas ce que ça va
donner ce train par contre je trouve
qu'au niveau du travail de recherche
préalable
là ils ont cartonné maintenant on va
prendre un petit rendez vous ensemble la
prochaine vidéo elle sera ce dimanche à
11 heures donc soyez là je dédicacerai
le livre le 24 juin à la rochelle le 28
juin à côté d'eux quand vous avez les
infos sur mon site internet dans la
section livres ou dans la vidéo dont je
vous mets le lien dans la description
est évidemment le livre est toujours
dans toutes les librairies fnac amazon
etc et maintenant je veux pas vous
challenge est malade et refuse je fais
une vidéo sur ce sujet on a été premier
des tendances donc je compte sur vos
pouces vos partages vos commentaires
parce que vous êtes au top les mecs
rendez vous dimanche à 11h ciao